here and it's time for that beautiful
Autumn decor and Brooke Fritz from
Clover and stem is here to show us how
we can do it ourselves yes it's so easy
you're going to be amazed you made these
these I made the whole Autumn wreath yes
right and so you're going to teach us
how we can I'm going to teach you how
easy it is I brought three different
styles okay so to show you the first
thing you need is a form any kind of
form there's several different kinds
there's a metal kind there's wood okay
you can get these cute beaded kinds
isn't this cute just at any craft store
any craft store and then there's this
kind of form there it just depends on
what look you like okay so first you
need to start with a form and I'm going
to show you first how I did this now I
took a metal form for this and I went
and cut this down in my backyard these
were are from your backyard I was just
gonna ask that do you buy this and no
you can just go do some hard work and
make it yourself do yard work get it for
free this is brilliant so the first
thing you want to do is you want to cut
down your Greenery from your backyard
okay and then you get a cluster of
greenery and you're going to place it
down onto your form and you're you're
going to need a wire spool like this
okay okay you'll put your Greenery down
and you're going to wrap it three to
four times tightly okay now you don't
want to cut the wire
you want to leave the wire long on this
okay okay now you do recommend using
your own Greenery or is it okay to use
your neighbor's Greenery yeah use your
members in the middle of this because
they have better Greenery than I do all
right cool awesome
so and then you're gonna get another
cluster of greenery and you want to
Overlay so you hide that wire okay and
you're going to lay that down and then
you can wrap it around if you want to
try it's super easy just wrap it twice
three times just make it tight and
that's good that's good okay at the end
if you didn't make it tight just tight
make it tight then you're going to do
the same thing you're going to get a
cluster of greenery and you're going to
place it onto your form you're going to
wrap wrap wrap until it looks like this
and then you have some little ribbons
there in the middle yeah you can leave
it plain if you like that look or you
can put some tassels and some ribbons
hanging down it's super easy that's
beautiful yeah so then something like
this one here I this is like my total
aesthetic okay this is my favorite too
this is pampus grass and it's everybody
loves Pampas and including me so pampas
grass you make it the exact same way as
this you wrap wrap wrap but something
about pampas grass is it sheds as you
can see it's kind of on the tablecloth
and one of the tricks is that why
there's hairs right here yes I wanted to
show you my trick Sprite girlfriend
bigger hair the better yeah so it'll
lock it and secure it all together so it
doesn't fly everywhere and make a mess
of your house I they're growing
sometimes or maybe it's something else
no is that growing can you just chop
that and spray it or yes I always want
to stop and ask neighbors can I have
here my neighbors are in trouble because
they have a lot of that stuff Brooke I
want to mention something because you
are not just good at do DIY projects but
just design in general you design a
brand new green room and it is
absolutely incredible do you offer your
services I do people how do people get
in touch with you um you can find me at
Clover and stem or Clover and stem
creatives and that's where you can find
me I I love it I love it okay on
Instagram on Instagram on Instagram yeah
I know we probably are going to run out
of time but I just I feel bad leaving
this alone this is so simple you guys
you just glue gun this is all dried
florals and just glue it on with a hot
glue gun and voila you have an amazing
wreath I bet your house looks great oh
this time of year this is my favorite
time yeah I love it thank you so much
and reach out to Brooke for all of your
design or DIY needs she's got some great
great ideas thank you so much thank you
so much